An aids muss heute niemand mehr sterben und es gibt ein medikament gegen die
immunschwächekrankheit der haken bisher das medikament war einfach nahezu unbezahlbar und das hat sich jetzt dramatisch geändert
Ob und wie es jetzt aufgehalten werden kann und wie es vor allem mit der hiv impfung steht jetzt in klink vom science fiction
herzlich willkommen
Die zahl die es wirklich heftig schätzungsweise sind bisher wohl 35 millionen menschen an der immunschwächekrankheit hiv
gestorben doch der plan gegen die
therapierbare aber immer noch
unheilbare erkrankung ist klar bis 2020 soll das zunächst einmal das 90 90 90 ziel seien
langfristig geht es dann darum aids komplett auszurotten und zwar bereits zum jahr
2030 fangen wir mal mit einer guten nachricht an die kosten für hiv therapien sind in den letzten jahren
Enorm gesunken etwa 80 dollar kostet jetzt ein jahr therapie das ist im vergleich zu der ersten
antiretroviralen therapie gegen hiv nichts pro patient und jahr waren nämlich damals satte
15.000 us dollar zu zahlen kaum jemand konnte das geld aufbringen und nicht weniger schlimm für die erkrankten war dass sie pro tag an die
zwanzig verschiedene medikamente nehmen muss mittlerweile
Haben betroffene die eine therapie erhalten eine normale lebenserwartung dazu kommt wird die erkrankung frühzeitig
behandelt schützt sie zu
96% auch vor einer hiv-übertragung so gesehen hat die forschung tatsächlich viel erreicht und auch der
gesellschaftliche umgang mit dem thema hat sich enorm verbessert mittlerweile herrscht weltweit eine wirklich große solidarität
Im kampf gegen aids und das ist auch gut so michael
Sidibé leitet das aids programm der vereinten nationen un hat vor kurzem ein interview mit dem tagesspiegel
spiegel geführt und dachte gesagt zitat der schulterschluss zwischen politik zivilgesellschaft
Und wissenschaft hat nicht nur die krankheit selbst in die zange genommen sondern noch etwas ganz anderes bewirkt alle menschen haben ein
Recht auf den zugang zu medikamenten heute können wir zum ersten mal sagen dass mehr hiv
Infizierte mit einer therapie leben als ohne
insgesamt werden demnach knapp
21 millionen von knapp 37 millionen hiv erkrankten mit der sogenannten
antiretroviralen
Therapie versorgt ein noch krassere vergleich vor knapp 18 jahren wurden in südafrika
90 menschen behandelt heutzutage sind es vier millionen und die ziele für die nächsten jahre sind
Die große vision eine welt komplett unaids und das solle in zwei schritten erreicht werden bis zum jahr
2020 und das ist ja nicht mehr lang hin soll das 90 90 90 ziel erreicht werden 90 prozent
Sollen ihren hiv status kennen 90 prozent sollen zugang zu therapien haben und weitere 90 prozent
Sollen eine virus last unter der nachweisgrenze haben
2014 haben die vereinten nationen das aids projekt un aids ins leben gerufen und im september
2015 war es dann zumindest in einem land soweit schweden hat als erstes land die 90 90 90 zähler erreicht in deutschland
Könnte eine pille zur prävention dazu beitragen nachzuziehen seit 2016 gibt es die sogenannte prä
exposition
prophylaxe wie sie im
Medizinische fachsprache genannt wird in der szene wird sie einfach nur prep genannt die die sie nennen sind die sogenannten treffer vor allem unter den
homosexuellen sind sie beliebt und wird diese gruppe schon fast etwas
So etwas wie eine sexuelle revolution geworden denn sie sorgt für sorgenfreies ex die beiden wirkstoffe tenofovir
und emtricitabin
Sollen dafür sorgen dass sich der hi virus nicht vermehren kann das sind übrigens genau dieselben wirkstoffe die bei
hiv-positiven den ausbruch der krankheit verhindern sollen 2015 zeigten unter anderem zwei große studien aus europa dass die pille
tatsächlich vor einer hiv-infektion schützen kann in beiden studien lag der schutz bei 86
War und er würde wahrscheinlich bei rund 100 prozent liegen wenn das medikament richtig eingenommen würde man
Muss sie nämlich mindestens fünf tage vor dem ungeschützten verkehr ab diesem tag
wo sollen sie jeden tag einnehmen
und
Ja das wäre würde dann bedeuten dass die pille hiv komplett austrocknen könnte kritiker dagegen warnen durch die pille werden mehr
geschlechtskrankheiten übertragen wie tripper syphilis und so weiter der grund
risikogruppen wiegen sich in falscher sicherheit und benutzten seltener kondome dennoch gab es vor allem in den letzten monaten einen regelrechten boom
Um diese pille gegen hiv denn seit oktober
2017 kostet sie noch nur noch 51 euro
Im monat vorher waren es rund 800 euro um die 90 90 90 ziele weltweit zu schaffen muss aber noch mehr passieren hiv test beispielsweise
müssten zu einer
selbstverständlichkeit werden das ist vor allem in manchen südlichen teil von afrika
Noch nicht der fall weil sich die männer dort nicht testen lassen sind 80 prozent der neu infizierten
Jugendlichen mädchen anders dagegen sieht es im afrikanischen staat zwar zeeland aus dass 90 90 90 ziel ist bereits jetzt
erreicht noch vor fünf jahren herrschte hier die höchste infektionsrate
weltweit vor allem die
Intensive aufklärungsarbeit hat hier wunder gewirkt für die nächste zeit stehen hier vor allem die themen bildung und sexualerziehung
auf dem tippzettel die zahl der hiv-infizierten
Könnte sinken wenn vor allem die mädchen die schule zu ende bringen könnten und das ist finanziell nicht wirklich ein mammutprojekt
lediglich zehn dollar pro kopf im monat
werden dafür veranschlagt
zudem könnte afrika auch geholfen werden wenn das land eigene
medikamente produzieren könnte eben diese bei denen der patentschutz schon abgelaufen ist mit ganz anderen problemen
dagegen haben die region in zentralasien und osteuropa
Zu kämpfen dort ist die zahl der neuinfektionen seit 2010
Um mehr als die hälfte gestiegen ein großteil davon macht russland aus zudem gibt es einen weiteren
Negativtrend auch die zahl derjenigen die an aids sterben nimmt zu das liegt unter anderem daran dass die betroffenen dort ihre krankheit nicht
Kommunizieren um hilfe, zu bekommen viele von ihnen werden diskriminiert sie sind häufig homosexuell transgender
drogenabhängige oder prostituierte
russland hätte das potential aids bis 2030 endgültig zu bekämpfen doch dafür müsste entschieden gegen die stigmatisierung
vorgegangen werden ein sehr großes problem weltweit aber auch in deutschland ist die zunehmende gleichgültigkeit
Es gibt studien nach denen es vor allem die sehr jungen menschen sind die sich nicht mehr schützen und das könnte tatsächlich dazu führen
Dass die welt in zukunft
Weiterhin mit es zurecht kommen muss das robert koch institut schreibt in seinem
epidemiologischen bulletin vom november 2017 dass die strategie zur eindämmung von hiv
weiter konsequent umgesetzt werden sollte
insbesondere durch
eine weitere verbesserung
Der test angebote und die gewährleistung des zugangs zur therapie für alle in deutschland von hiv betroffenen menschen inklusive
der menschen ohne krankenversicherung
Eine weitere idee sind selbst tests für zu hause da verspricht sich zum beispiel die deutsche aids-hilfe aus denn das könnte den schritt erleichtern
überhaupt einen hiv test zu machen andere sehen das kritisch weil dabei natürlich die ärztliche beratung fehlt in deutschland
dürfen solche selbst setzen noch nicht abgegeben werden auch in anderen europäischen ländern wie den niederlanden
Ist das möglich immer mal wieder gibt es ja auch meldungen zu einer möglichen aids impfung doch in den letzten jahrzehnten
Habe es nur sehr wenige von ihnen bis in die letzte
Studienphase geschafft keiner davon ist bislang auf dem markt fleisch ist ja auch
Dass nur noch eine frage der zeit doch darauf ausruhen sollten wir uns nicht dazu
Michelle sidibé ich glaube an die impfung aber sie wird hiv nicht auslöschen eine impfung wird niemals hundertprozentig schützen
Auch wenn sie etliche infektionen verhindern könnte seiner meinung nach
Sei es wichtig an ganz vielen fronten
zu kämpfen und zwar wie schon gesagt
Beispielsweise zugang zu bildung und wissen schaffen und die diskriminierung von aids patienten und patientinnen
Bekämpfen wenn ihr kein video zu diesem thema und auch zu allen anderen dem verpassen wollt dann tut mehr
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke denn nur dann werdet ihr auch
Immer über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit dafür. Draufklicken eine krankheit schlimmer als aids ja ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran